-Our first guest tonight
is a very talented actor,
you know, from films like
"The Last King of Scotland,"
"Atonement,"
and the "X-Men" franchise.
You can see him in
"The Book of Clarence,"
which is in theaters
January 12th.
Please welcome back to the show,
James McAvoy, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome back.
-Whoa.
I think I know what your
first question is going to be.
-What's my first question
going to be?
-How did I put
my pants on?
How did you.
[ Laughter ]
-He getting mad 'cause I've got
people that do it for me.
-You have people.
You have a team of people.
Because, you know,
I usually go in dressing rooms
and there's usually someone
for hair and someone for makeup.
But your room also had
those two guys
who each had one side
of a pair of pants.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, just big shout out
to the pant people.
They are --
They're really important.
-They almost never get thanked
in award speeches.
-You know, I wouldn't be here
without the pant people.
And I'm just like, big up,
big up the pant people.
-You know, it's nice because,
I mean,
I don't know a single actor
who does it themselves.
And it's very big of you
to admit it.
-Listen, I think it's a story
that needed to be told
for a long time.
[ Laughter ]
It's going to be
a big expose on Netflix.
It's about the pant people.
It's a whole part of the
subculture of the industry.
Yeah, I'm going deep here
with this.
-You're going deep.
Yeah.
I'm going deep
with this riff, um...
[ Laughter ]
The pant people need to be
recognized.
-They need to be recognized.
-You know who's hard
to find?
Uh, corduroy guys.
Because it's a whole --
You really need three guys
for a pair of corduroy.
-Back in the '70s when,
you know, we were 30.
-Yeah.
-Um.
Those guys --
Those guys got recognized.
But these days,
they're just disposed.
-Yeah, it's true.
Thank you for a shout
out to the pant people.
-All right.
Thank you.
-Um, hey, also, Happy New Year.
-Hey.
-I mean, first guest of 2024.
It means a lot.
-Hey, I first footed you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It means a lot to me,
actually.
Actually,
they told me that and I was --
I was, uh, I was I
was impressed with myself.
Um. Uh, yeah.
I've literally first footed you.
-Oh, first footed. Okay.
Now, I don't know
what that means.
-Er.
[ Chuckles ]
So in Scotland, where --
[ Heavy accent ] where
I come from, in my country.
[ Normal voice ] It is, um,
which is not the accent
of my country, um,
or possibly any country.
[ Laughter ]
Uh, the first footing tradition
is the, um,
the first person
that comes into your house
needs to carry something.
-On the new year?
-Yeah.
-So after midnight.
-After midnight,
after the bells.
We call it the bells.
When -- When New year strikes,
the first person
that comes into your house
has to be bringing
something good.
Like some food, some coal,
traditionally coal
to keep your house warm
and to keep you fed.
And if the first person
that comes into your house
doesn't have these things,
bad luck ensues.
So what ends up happening is
that whoever is in your house,
like your child,
or your best friend,
or your, I don't know,
the wife of your child
or something like that,
someone you don't care
about very much
has to go outside in the cold.
And when everybody else
is cheering
and singing "Auld Lang Syne"
and kissing and things
like that,
they're standing outside
in the snow,
freezing, holding a lump of coal
and a glass of drink.
And -- And as long
as in the new year,
they're the first person
to cross your threshold,
they bring good luck.
-Gotcha. So you're basically
like you're fixing the game.
You're like, we're going
to put some good luck outside.
-You're you're playing the man
at his own game.
-And it does seem like a lousy
job because it's cold.
-Yeah. It sucks.
-And how early do
they send you out?
-Uh, it's only like five,
ten minutes,
but you miss the good bit.
I remember the first time
my wife came to
Glasgow for New Year.
Um, all the men
had to go outside
so that the men
were first footing
the women,
which is great.
You know, all the women
got first footed.
Sounds terrible doesn't it?
[ Laughter ]
It sounds like some awful orgy.
And, um, and, uh, my wife
was like at the time going,
this is -- this sucks.
You know, usually
the bells strike
and we all get to kiss
at 12:00, you know?
But we were all outside
and we missed each other,
so all the women were together.
All the -- It was segregation,
basically segregation.
-I like that all the women
were telling her, like,
I know this seems bad now,
but don't worry,
James will be back soon
and he'll have coal.
-He'll have coal.
-I don't know.
what's the name of --
What's the name
of New Year's Eve in Scotland?
They just call it New Year's?
-No, we call it Hogmanay.
-Hogmanay.
-It's spelt Hogmanay.
So extend the "nay" as in,
like you're going "naaay", um.
And -- And it's spelt "hog.'
But we say it "hug" -- Hogmanay.
-Hogmanay.
-And, uh, and that's been around
for a long time.
I mean, it doesn't seem
like first footing
is like a modern invention.
-No, no, it's fairly old.
I don't know why we call it
Hogmanay,
but, um, we call it Hogmanay.
-I will say earlier today,
uh,
you know, my segment producer
came in and said,
"McAvoy is spinning this tale
that they call it
Hogmanay and first footing
and all this craziness."
And we thought, you know, we
thought you were making it up.
We got a Scottish guy on staff
and, uh, he signed off.
He said it all made sense.
Yeah.
-Good man.
Man. He's in on the game, too.
[ Laughter ]
-You guys all know
each other, don't you?
Um, you're also here
promoting a film,
and we should talk about it.
But first, let's take
a quick commercial break
and we'll be right back.
You guys, that's James McAvoy.
We'll be right back.